confiné dans sa forteresse senioriales
du 15e au 21ème siècle patricia laigneau
n'y avais pas pensé
elle profite de son jardin et de saipan
avec caroline sa fille est souvent seule
bravo bravo
ils n'arrêtent pas maroco ils me disent
les jo il dit mais où sont les visiteurs
les visiteurs d'habitude ils viennent
dès le printemps pour admirer les
glaïeuls de byzance et tout un tas
d'autres espèces rares
ici c'est la mauve royal et celle ci en
plus elle est à feuilles variés gata ça
veut dire de deux couleurs et elle est
assortie harmonisé avec ce très beau
rozier qui s'est emparée de cet arbre
etc le rusé qui s'appelle plaisanterie
patricia avait préparé son tapis de
tulipes en rouge et noir avec quelques
surprises
mais regardez cette équipe elle est
assez extraordinaire c'est la tulipe up
1 fleur d'anémone celle ci s'appelle
l'oncle tom
alors depuis le confinement elle joue du
smartphone en direct ou en photo pour
partager ses iris blanc ou ses pivoines
arbustives japonaise admirable éphémère
je crois que c'est aussi un recours dans
cette période triste que nous vivons de
voir la beauté de la nature la beauté
des fleurs et donc tous les jours
nous lançons un live ou bien
sur instagram je photographie des photos
des plus belles floraisons patricia
repompe son jardin profite seul du
spectacle des fleurs des belles lumières
du printemps sur le parc où le château
le printemps est presque passé et un
petit peu plus tard on aura la fleur
noir désir être menée grande qui va se
sortir surgir au milieu de ce parterre
argenté en attendant elle retire les
indésirables des massifs prépare le
jardin comme si la vie normale reprenez
demain si c'est très grand 1
on risque pas de se rentrer l'un dans
l'autre un sais pas comment ça
supermarché supermarchés sont ouverts
non pas pourquoi pas les jardins